what you call love was invented by guys
like me to sell nylons you're on a first
date marries the girl you want to really
impress her how do you make her feel
special well start off with some
fabulous food a little fabulous
conversation what else fabulous job
ended with a fabulous foot massage for
an evening of total fabulous look my job
is to introduce your headphones to a
huge drunk
male audience again in all deference to
the week's Bob spent trying to develop
ties with Chevy I think it's best if I
bring in my own team so you won't forget
yeah this is : cute name
genie do you understand having you out
here is the same as having no one he
said it was a surprise a surprise well
thank you for that here's a surprise
wasn't he great he seems nice he can rap
about anything
he's totally cracking me up on the best
this when are you allowed to use the
words long term in this office
it'll be 1973 before we're even great so
you have it no store has this version
now what do I do
you get it free let me understand you
don't have the video but you're gonna
tell me how to get it free your
activities last night I've cost us this
account what go ahead tell him how you
corrupted my account and my friend well
in a few moments I'm gonna put on my
Versace overcoat get into my Mercedes
drive to my Fifth Avenue apartment and
squeeze my girlfriend's big fake boobs
look I will apologize face to face as
horrible as that will be but I think you
there's no reason to let me go
lucky for me I already have my dream job
you're on your corporation
oh you're right my job sucks she can
smell the Cleo Don remember your first
big ad she has her heart set on it I'll
miss you too Pheebs and I will be
holding you right here
Oh expect to see you negative for a
visit
hey thanks for the subtext nice gun dog
makes you look tough what are you doing
walking all by your lonesome
come on the movies in
thank Pete there's nothing to discuss I
like Bob Chevy likes Bob and if you
don't like Bob we can find someone who
does
have courage princess what can it be
three circles joy two moons and a crown
I guess I'd off the phone with UFC and
they're having the Nixon boys stop by at
the end of the week with Nixon No thank
God otherwise I'd have to move the piano
out of my office
now there you are yes there's that face
that face that somehow I trust